تم إجلاء جميع الموظفين الدبلوماسيين في هارتم في السودان وأفراد
أسرهم
من السفارة في
عاصمة السودان بالخرطوم بالطائرة
وهم في طريقهم بأمان خارج
البلاد ، وهو
تطور هام وإيجابي بشكل لا يصدق خاصة بالنظر إلى
أسبوع القتال الذي  كانت ولاية وزارة الدفاع الأمريكية
وآخرون
يراقبون عن كثب ما يحدث في السودان ، وكانوا
يبحثون عن نافذة للخروج كانوا
يعلمون أن هذه الفترة في نهاية هذا الأسبوع
قد تكون في الأساس تلك الفترة التي أقام فيها النسر عطلة في نهاية شهر رمضان.
فصيلان متحاربان هناك
ولكن وقف إطلاق النار لم يكن Ironclad
كانت هناك انتهاكات معقدة لوقف
إطلاق النار تعقد
عملية الدخول والخروج
وبالطبع القرار بالقيام بذلك ولكن مرة أخرى
سمعنا للتو من مسؤول أمريكي
قبل وقت قصير أن  تم إجلاء جميع
موظفي السفارة في الخرطوم وأفراد عائلاتهم
مع
مغادرتهم ، وهذا هو إغلاق
السفارة الأمريكية في السودان في الوقت الحالي ،
ومن غير الواضح أين هم بالضبط في
هذه المرحلة أو أين هم.  إذا
كانوا سيبقون في المجال الجوي السوداني ، فإن
الاتجاه الذي سيتجهون إليه
سيكون إلى جيبوتي حيث كان لدى الولايات المتحدة
عدة مئات من مشاة البحرية الأمريكية على استعداد للذهاب كجزء
من هذا أو إلى مكان آخر ، كل
ذلك يظل جزءًا من الأسئلة هنا
ولكن  العامل الرئيسي مرة أخرى قال مسؤول أمريكي لشبكة
CNN أن موظفي السفارة في
الخرطوم في السودان تمكنوا من
الإخلاء على عدة طائرات عسكرية